Muy buenas tardes Pues usted lo ha dicho
Bien muchísimas sorpresas la que se
vivió en la cancha central aquí en el
efectivamente con este brasileño que
saltó a la cancha quedándose con la
primera manga a pesar de que ya después
el ruso se quedó con los dos siguientes
sets mostrando que estaba como en
control de este partido aprovechando
errores bastante garrafales por parte de
seguramente cayendo un poco ante la
presión ante los nervios sin embargo
volvió a digamos a encontrar su
tranquilidad para quedarse con el cuarto
set y finalmente pues llevar este
partido a una batalla de más de cuatro
horas quinto set y pues
aprovechó En todo caso en ese quinto set
no solamente para quebrar el servicio
del ruso sino también para terminar ese
partido con una derecha invertida que
fue absolutamente letal para Daniel
Marbella En todo caso pues todo Una gran
sorpresa para este brasileño es él es el
172 en el ranking mundial Es la primera
vez que lograba disputar un partido en
el cuadro principal de Roland garros
había llegado aquí clasificándose y
bueno ahora está esperando a la ganador
entre guido pela y el francés
jalis para la segunda ronda Natalia y
además de este jovencísimo brasileño
también participaron también compitieron
otros latinoamericanos cómo les fue
pues ha sido más bien un día bueno para
los latinoamericanos Empezando por el
chileno Nicolás yarrique derrotó Bueno a
otro jugador de la región a los
bolivianos Hugo de Liliana en un partido
en tres sets Esto fue más temprano
también en la mañana el oso colombianos
Juan Sebastián cabal y Robert ganaron a
la dupla Argentina de androsy y
echeverry una buena también sorpresa
para los argentinos con la victoria de
Genaro olivieri Quien ganó al francés en
una batalla de cinco sets y hace pocos
instantes fue Francisco cerúndolo Quien
ganó su partido ante Jaime munar el
español Así que como verán una buena
jornada Todavía queda un partido
importante para los latinoamericanos el
partido de esta noche en el que jugará
Sebastián báez otro argentino una gran
presencia por parte de los argentinos
aquí en este torneo que se enfrentará al
francés de muchísima experiencia
el francés que espera ganar su primer
partido este año